sayah on est dans ce qu'il convient
d'appeler la nouvelle à dernière pardon
ligne droite on est à moins de deux
semaines du premier tour à chaque
gardien oui j - 13 raphaël avant le
premier tour et la campagne s'accélère
enfin
meeting contre meeting le week-end
dernier les candidats ont profité du
beau temps pour rassembler leurs
partisans l'heure est à la mobilisation
alors que l'abstention pourrait battre
des records cette année la faute à une
campagne qui n'a pas réussi à passionner
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire en tout
cas son coup d'envoi officiel a été
donné aujourd'hui les douze candidats au
scrutin des 10 et 24 avril bénéficie
désormais d'une stricte égalité de temps
de parole dans les médias radios et
télés le récap politique est signée
florent au dos et lucie la tour
c'est l'histoire d'une campagne qui
s'accélère rien que ce dimanche quatre
meetings et pas des moindres en perte de
vitesse dans les sondages eric zemmour
n'a pas choisi au hasard le trocadéro où
la droite s'est réunie en 2012 et 2017
l'opération séduction des électeurs des
républicains se poursuit nous sommes les
seuls héritiers d'une droite qui aiment
la france le peuple le travail l'ordre
et l'identité
retenti ensuite la marseillaise
havre
pas la pire fausses notes de l'après
midi
ses mots eric zemmour dit ne pas les
avoir entendus réponse cinglante du
président-candidat en déplacement à
dijon il ya deux hypothèses la première
c'est la dignité et au sel ce qui me
semble la plus crédible la deuxième
c'est la méconnaissance d'une réforme
très importante du quinquennat c'est le
100% santé et maintenant les prothèses
auditives les lunettes et les prothèses
dentaires sont remboursés par la
sécurité sociale et j'invite alors à ce
moment là le candidat malentendants à
pouvoir s'équiper à moindre coût lui a
choisi la plage du prado à marseille son
fief jean luc mélenchon la sueur avec sa
retraite à 60 ans il est le cauchemar
des manuels macro et de marine le pen
monsieur macron c'est le programme
économique de madame le pen plus le
mépris de classe
madame le pen c'est le programme
économique de monsieur macro plus que
mépris drache
macron le pen dans le même sac fabien
hausse et lui ajoute de nom à cette
liste
quand vous écoutez les macron les
pécresse les zemmour les le pen ils sont
différents mais ils ont un programme
commun quand le medef parle il exécute
eh ben il est temps que les cigares
change de bouche toulouse anne hidalgo y
était aussi la veille moins de monde
mais une même critique d'un vote utile à
gauche nommé mélenchon mélenchon c'est
l'impasse
mais quelle ville quel département
quelle région son mouvement at il gagné
avec ce sectarisme et ses outrances
à vélo et avec le sourire au zénith de
paris premier grand meeting pour yannick
jadot qui compte plus que jamais sur la
jeunesse pour faire gagner l'écologie
jeunes de france fait irruption dans ce
scrutin
venez nous bousculer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve demain
et puis beaucoup de réactions ces
derniers jours sur la ferme à qinze et
voilà dix jours qu'un rapport du sénat a
dénoncé le large recours du gouvernement
au cabinet de conseil parmi lesquels
donc l'américain mckinsey qui n'aurait
payé aucun impôt en france entre 2011 et
2020 grâce à de l'optimisation fiscale
sur la défensive emmanuel macron
démentent toute combiné assure qu'il
n'ya rien d'illégal ses adversaires sont
nombreux à parler de scandale d'état
écouter à ce sujet nicolas du point
pourquoi des consultants américains qui
font d'ailleurs de l'optimisation
fiscale remplace des hauts
fonctionnaires qui font des années
d'études qui sont encadrés et et qui
conseille en même temps l'état et des
entreprises privées c'est un conflit
d'intérêt majeur e mais je ne sais pas
si vous réalisez ce qui s'est passé et
je vous le dis je demande aux français
de sanctionner gravement emmanuel macron
marine le pen elle s'est rendue aux
antilles françaises oui une première
pour elle depuis qu'elle a pris la tête
du rassemblement national s'est donc
rendue en guadeloupe samedi d'où elle a
envoyé quelques tweets enthousiaste sa
soirée a toutefois été perturbé par un
groupe de manifestants présentés comme
des nationalistes guadeloupéens ils ont
fait irruption vous le voyez dans son
hôtel alors qu'elle était en train
d'enregistrer une émission elle ensuite
dû être évacués et un représentant des
mamans quand c'est justifié dénonçant
les idées d'extrême droite porté par la
candidate celle ci a dû modifier ensuite
le programme de son week-end pour
raisons de sécurité
malgré tout marine le pen affiche ses
ambitions arriver donc en tête en
guadeloupe territoire pourtant réputé
hostile aux idées du rn comme l'ensemble
des antilles au niveau national
maintenant elle est toujours donnée
secondes dans les intentions de vote
elle resserre même l'écart avec emmanuel
macron on va le voir selon un sondage
ifop elle rassemble 21 % des intentions
de vote un progrès de deux points et
demi en une seule en une semaine on en
parle ce soir avec notre collègue
reporter clovis casali qui couvre la
campagne de l'extrême droite pour
france24 bonsoir clovis la stratégie de
normalisation de marine le pen a l'air
de fonctionner déjà c'est quoi la
normalisation cette fameuse
dédiabolisation c'est ne pas paraître
d'extrême droite et c'est ce qu'elle
essaie de faire alors peut-être dans son
programme elle paraît moins d'extrême
droite en tout cas tout est dans une
tout est une question de perception et
elle disait récemment il ya trois jours
je crois aux lecteurs du parisien marine
le pen que les positions caricaturales
d'eric zemmour à sa droite finalement la
rendre la rendent plus acceptable et on
le voit dans ce dernier sondage mâcon
28% le pen 21 zemmour 11% à égalité avec
pécresse donc il semblerait que les
efforts de marine le pen marche pourtant
elle a perdu sa nièce qui est allé chez
m chez zemmour à marion maréchal
marine le pen qui semble plus isolé que
jamais et pourtant on le voit
excusez moi ça va plutôt bien pour la
candidate du rassemblement national et
oui avec un eric zemmour qui après une
entrée de campagne en fanfare ne lui fit
finalement pas tant d'onde que ça cloris
c'est pour ça qu'il y a eu ce grand
rassemblement au trocadéro dans la
lignée de ceux de sarkozy en 2012 de
fillon en 2010 est important pour eric
zemmour mais en même temps on peut se
poser quand même beaucoup de questions
parce qu'il y à toutes ces défections on
a parlé de marion maréchal il y en a
d'autres il ya des poids lourds des
anciens poids lourds du rassemblement
national gilbert collard stéphane ravier
à nicolas bay ce sont des gens qui
symbolisait les victimes du
rassemblement national et à l'époque du
front national aux législatives aux
municipales alors comment va-t-elle
faire si un jour elle gouverne avec qui
elle pourrait gouverner marine le pen
difficile de le savoir là on se projette
après une élection présidentielle mais
même pour des législatives même pour du
municipal qui va constituer les
effectifs si on peut dire du
rassemblement national et c'est un
problème pour l on sait qu il y a
quelques années elle avait du mal à
recruter elle avait du mal à présenter
des candidats y avait même des ateliers
de formation je me rappel lors d'une
université d'été du fn à l'époque donc
marine le pen apparaît plus isolé que
jamais au sein des politiques de son
mouvement politique et quand on lui pose
la question on l'a fait notamment à
reims elle elle répond vous inquiétez
pas assez des hommes politiques qui déjà
s'était détaché de moi qui déjà ne
partagez pas nos points de vue et de
toute façon ce ne sont pas de grosses
pertes il semblerait en tout cas que
dans les sondages ça va plutôt bien pour
marine le pen et quand on interroge son
électorat ils disent eh bien ces gens là
les belles et collard s'ils ne sont pas
contents rassemblement national qu'il
parte mais la stratégie de marine le pen
actuellement est la bonne cette
stratégie c'est la normalisation merci
clovis pour cet éclairage et on veut
maintenant visionner le reportage que
vous avez réalisé hier au meeting d'eric
zemmour place du trocadéro à paris une
démonstration de force qui s'inscrit
dans les pas vous l'avez dit de nicolas
sarkozy et de françois fillon qui avait
organisé des meetings respectivement en
2012 et 2017 d'anciens fillonniste sont
d'ailleurs séduit aujourd'hui par le
discours d'eric zemmour qui prône
l'union des droites reportage donc de
clovis casali et eloïse mais
le meeting va débuter et en coulisses
l'équipe d'eric zemmour s'activent
une vidéo du candidat d'extrême droite
résonne place du trocadéro
[Musique]
de quoi faire patienter la foule
samuel la faune et les militants de
reconquête veille à ce que l'événement
suscite aussi l'engouement sur internet
l'e mailing en a bouffé sur sociaux et
la création de contenu des basses et
déjà les 100 mille tweets se rasait mon
cadet works le meeting est pas commencé
ça va être l'événement la campagne plus
ancienne
figure de la manif pour tous opposé au
mariage homosexuel
il était déjà au trocadéro en 2017 pour
françois fillon il faisait partie de
l'équipe réseaux sociaux du candidat des
républicains
[Applaudissements]
ayant voté pour françois fillon avait
déboisé mots ces mères comme des la
présentielle et c'est celui qui a le
plus
à
droite
avec son discours décomplexé sur
l'immigration et la sécurité zemmour
séduit chez d'anciens fillonniste et
membres des républicains comme ce groupe
de la sarthe
pour nous c'est essentiel de venir pour
montrer au monde que le français n'a pas
dit son dernier mot et qu'on ne nous
volera pas la france la france elle est
à nous et dans notre coeur comme dit
notre futur cannes du président il
faudrait nous arracher le coeur pour
nous prendre la france voilà le combat
il va permettre de renvoyer chez eux les
immigrés qu'on peut pas accueillir chez
nous
donc assainir la france y en a grand
besoin
zemmour rêve de mener l'union des
droites de marion maréchal à guillaume
pelletier il a recruté d'anciennes
figures et rennes où l air d prise de
choix et pourtant pas de percée dans les
sondages
voilà donc pour ce reportage petites
questions supplémentaires clovis cette
phrase quand dès hier par la foule lors
du meeting de l'eczéma ou maquereau
assassin a beaucoup choqué une
atmosphère particulière n'est ce pas
c'est un peu tendu on a entendu macron
assassins on a aussi entendu macron
collabos à plusieurs reprises et ça on
n'en a pas parlé en tout cas ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que ce qui est
intéressant dans ce rassemblement c'est
aussi à la haine des médias la haine des
élites mans s'est fait traiter
d'islamophobe schiste qui ait jamais
forcément très sympathique on a eu ces
commentaires et véritablement chez
zemmour chez ses partisans on a
l'impression que personne ne voit la
dynamique que personne ne voit les
chiffres sur les réseaux sociaux le
nombre record de de vue sur les vidéos
et c'est vrai mais dans les sondages ça
ne se traduit pas zemmour on l'a dit est
à 11% dans lé dernier à sondages mais
dans le camp de ces aimants je peux vous
dire qu'ils sont persuadés qu'ils vont
être au second tour que les sondages se
trompent régulièrement et que les médias
les journalistes les élites se trompe en
disant élites à l'idée dans votre cas
chez vous a longtemps beaucoup chez
merci beaucoup clovis pour cet éclairage
est je le rappelle vous retrouve sur les
antennes francophone et anglophone de
france 24 tout au long de cette campagne
ce reportage également sont à revoir sur
le site internet de france 24 on en
vient notre archive du jour oui elle
fait écho à la visite mouvementée on l'a
vu de marine le pen en guadeloupe
archives de son père jean-marie en
décembre 1997 il était alors à la tête
du front national en s'être du r'n
vivement prise à partie à l'aéroport de
fort de france en martinique par une
cinquantaine de militants
indépendantistes antiracistes qui vu
reprocher ses propres sur l'inégalité
des races et sur les chambres à gaz
point de détail disait-il de la seconde
guerre mondiale selon ses mots
voilà et c'est la fin de france 2022
l'heure du choix merci h rennes on se
retrouve dans dans 5 minutes pour un
nouveau journal dans pareils actes